gewaltig und teuer
in Empire Aufbau eines Imperiums oder
Entstehung einer neuen Weltordnung des
Handels
[Musik]
jetzt noch das Programm wird nicht von
China dominiert
vielmehr arbeitet China mit anderen
Ländern zusammen
Tentakel die sich aus China durch
Zentralasien und Europa den Nahen Osten
Afrika Indien und Südostasien ziehen auf
dem Land wie auf der See durch völlig
unerschlossene Wirtschaftsgebiete
Pleiten sind in der Infrastruktur immer
möglich
am Ende wird das Projekt China und seine
Partner Billionen Dollar kosten
diese Länder brauchen Infrastruktur Geld
wird der Antrieb sein
[Musik]
hallo ich bin's Steven Angel und zeige
Ihnen wie die älteste bestehende
Zivilisation der Welt die Zukunft ihrer
Wirtschaft gestalten will
baging erschafft mit der neuen
Seidenstraße eine neue Dynastie
Schnellzüge sind ein Symbol des
chinesischen Fortschritts so auch das
Tempo mit dem der Schienennetz ausgebaut
wird die Züge sind über 300 km/h schnell
für manche sind sie auch Sinnbild der
ehrgeizigen neuen Seidenstraße
entgegen häufiger Irrtümer wird das
Programm nicht von China dominiert
mit anderen Ländern
Zusammenarbeit mit internationalen
Institutionen und Entwicklungsbanken
leider wird dies von manchen
missverstanden als chinesisches Programm
über das andere ausgenutzt und Chinas
Interessen geschützt werden sollen
das entspricht überhaupt nicht den
tatsachenfrastrukturprojekte kommen gut
an die Märkte brauchen dringend bessere
Verkehrsmittel und Straßen insbesondere
kleine und mittlere Staaten wurde
Infrastrukturausbau schwierig ist
bedenken
oft hört man aus betroffenen Ländern
dass chinesische Firmen steht den
größten Vorteil daraus ziehen
in den kommenden 10 15 Jahren werden
weltweit etwa 90 Billionen Dollar in
Infrastruktur investiert werden vor
allem in aufstrebenden Märkten und
Entwicklungsländern die Summe ist
gewaltig aber doch nur ein kleiner
Prozentsatz der weltweiten
Infrastrukturausgaben und vielleicht
weniger als 5% der Infrastrukturausgaben
in Asien
es ist ein sehr großes Projekt aber man
sollte es in seinem Kontext nicht
unnötig aufbauschen
[Musik]
im Grunde genommen will China die alte
Seidenstraße mit moderner Infrastruktur
wiederbelegen
wirtschaftskorridore einrichten helfen
verbinden und eine Seidenstraße zur Sie
einrichten die nach China zurückführt in
der Praxis erweist sich das als
kompliziert
bei 86 Ländern ist der schwierig zu
sagen welche Länder nicht zur neuen
Seidenstraße gehören
zudem verlief die alte Seidenstraße zur
See damals westwärts
durch die zunehmende Annäherung von
China und Lateinamerika könnte sie nun
aber auch nach Osten verlaufen
oder nach Afrika im Südwesten
es ist also ein Projekt für regionale
und globale Integration
anfangs ging es um Infrastruktur darum
überschüssiges Material zu nutzen doch
mittlerweile ist es so viel mehr es
entsteht ein ganzes Ökosystem durch das
Projekt
viele chinesische Firmen staatlich wie
privat sind beteiligt und wollen sich
beteiligen nicht nur wegen der
Seidenstraße sondern weil es eine
lukrative Chance ist
sie wachsen durch die hohen
Infrastrukturausgaben
der politische Aspekt ist ganz anders
als vor fünf Jahren
die neue Seidenstraße steht noch am
Anfang
sie ist noch in der Planungsphase es
gibt schon einige Projekte in
Zentralasien wie die Straße nach guarda
in Pakistan aber sie steht noch am
Anfang
es zeigt sich aber bereits die
grundlegende Idee die Welt näher an
Ostasien und ins besondere China
heranzuführen
mignum die chinesische Führung meines
Ernst das Projekt wurde in der
Verfassung der Kommunistischen Partei
verankert
auf gedei und Verderb wird das Projekt
als skijingpings Erbe in die Geschichte
eingehen
hat klar und deutlich gesagt wir werden
keinen Garten in unserem Hinterhof bauen
[Musik]
wir wollen einen wunderschönen Garten
voller wunderschöner Blumen bauen den
alle Länder der Welt genießen können
die neue Seidenstraße ist ein wichtiger
Schlüssel der Strategie Chinas und der
skijin Ping
es geht um die Geschichte vom Aufstieg
Chinas und das tatsächlich Ausmaß von
Chinas Wirtschaft und Handelsmacht
China ist nun wirtschaftlich fast gleich
auf mit den USA
je nachdem wie man es misst sogar größer
denn es betreibt viel mehr Handel als
die USA die neue Seidenstraße passt zur
Erzielung vom Aufstieg Chinas und von
der Offenheit Chinas in China sagen wir
wer hohe Ziele verfehlt erreicht immer
noch hohe Ergebnisse wer mittlere Ziele
verfehlt erzielt schwache Ergebnisse
China ist sehr ehrgeizig aber der
Ehrgeiz dient dem Wohle der ganzen Welt
zehn Länder machen fast 70 Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung der neuen
Seidenstraße aus
chinesische Firmen haben zwar manche
erfolgreichen Verträge abgeschlossen
müssen sich aber anpassen um sich gegen
koreanische japanische amerikanische
europäische oder lokale Firmen zu
behaupten seien sie nun türkisch oder
indisch sie müssen mit Ihnen
zusammenarbeiten
wenn in Südostasien Pakistan Kasachstan
oder Afrika Infrastruktur gebaut wird
sollte zuallererst das jeweilige Land
die Infrastruktur gestalten
das muss bei der Umsetzung der Idee
unbedingt beachtet werden
einfach diktiert wie die Infrastruktur
auszusehen habe scheitert das Projekt
neue Seewege Straßen Schienen Pipelines
und Häfen China super Highway nimmt
Gestalt an und bringt chinesische Ware
in alle Welt und alle Welt wiederum nach
China als nächstes wägen wir die Risiken
neuer unbekannte Handelswege ab
[Musik]
ohne Beine Herausforderung bei der
Umsetzung der neuen Seidenstraße wird
für China die Finanzierung sein es
werden kosten zwischen 4 und 8 Billionen
Dollar erwartet die große Frage ist
jedoch wie China im Umgang mit riskanten
wenig kreditwürdigen Ländern sein Geld
verwalten wird
von den etwa 70 Staaten die China als
Partner aufzählt gelten 27 als nicht
kreditwürdig für 14 weitere wie zum
Beispiel Afghanistan Iran und Syrien
gibt es nicht mal eine Bewertung
gleiten sind bei Infrastrukturprojekten
am Anfang immer möglich
darum ist die richtige Finanzierung zur
rechten Zeit am rechten Ort in
ausreichender Menge so entscheidend hier
wollen multilaterale Banken unterstützen
sie bringen sich im frühen hoch
riskanten Stadium ein und mildern das
Risiko
unser Vorgehen ist klar die Bank ist
inklusiv
wir zwingen niemandem böswillig diese
Bank auf denn es ist letztlich die
Entscheidung souveräner Regierungen
die Tür steht offen wir laden Sie ein
wer beitreten und mit anderen
Mitgliedern zusammenarbeiten will ist
uns willkommen
jede Regierung aber ihre eigenen
Vorstellungen
so viele Geschäfte zwischen Regierungen
könnten ein Problem sein aber die neue
Seidenstraße entwickelt sich weiter und
wir sehen zunehmend Profit gesteuerte
Geschäfte nicht nur zwischen staatlichen
sondern privaten Unternehmen
gerade Chinas Technologiefirmen drängen
in die Märkte der Seidenstraße um
marktgesteuerte Chancen zu nutzen
welche Rolle sollten Geschäftsbanken
dabei spielen auch sie wollen Risiken
vermeiden werden aber vielerorts von der
Politik beeinflusst
die Rolle der Geschäftsbanken ist sehr
wichtig insbesondere der internationalen
Geschäftsbanken
denn sie durchleuchten die Projekte
wählen Sie gewissenhaft aus und
finanzieren sie letztendlich auch
chinesische Behörden wissen das und ich
höre immer wieder dieselben Argumente
Zeit der internationalen Geschäftsbanken
wir werden nicht alle Projekte
finanzieren und wir wollen keine viel
Investitionen sondern sinnvolle Projekte
Transparenz und verantwortungsvolle
Staatsführung sind Herausforderungen für
die neue Seidenstraße
der neugewählte Premierminister von
Malaysia hat einige der Verträge seines
Vorgängers aufgehoben und in Sri Lanka
droht ein schuldenausfall das Projekt
vom Kurs abzubringen
Sri Lanka ist ein gutes Beispiel china
hat hier einen Hafen finanziert der sich
als nicht wirtschaftlich erwiesen hat
weshalb China ihm übernommen hat das
werden wir in kleinen anfälligeren
Ländern öfter beobachten Infrastruktur
klingt erstmal toll aber wenn die
Geschäfte dann ausbleiben bringt das
auch nichts
der Hafen von hamban toter wurde
errichtet ohne vorher
wirtschaftlichkeitsstudien durchzuführen
so geriet die regierungsri Lankas in die
Schuldenfalle und musste den Hafen für 9
Jahre an China vermieten
einschließlich eines gewaltigen
sechseinhalb Quadratkilometer großen
Gebietes um den Hafen herum
für Indien den größten Kritiker der
neuen Seidenstraße geht es um die
nationale Sicherheit
Chinas Mammutprojekt erstreckt sich
durch ganz Pakistan bis zur Hafenstadt
vada am Indischen Ozean
in Bezug auf die Seidenstraße zur See
muss man bedenken dass China
mittlerweile die Kontrolle oder eine
Anteils Mehrheit über 75 helfen in 35
Ländern erlangt hat in
seventies es ist dass sie dabei
sicherlich nicht nur kommerzielle
Interessen verfolgen
je näher man an China ist desto nervöser
sind die Reaktionen das sieht man zum
Beispiel in Indien
manche asienländer sind besorgt wegen
der strategischen Komponente
China gibt Kambodscha und Laos viel Geld
kauft sich quasi deren Freundschaft
diese wiederum geben China ein Veto in
Asian da das Bündnis übereinstimmigkeit
funktioniert
im Bezug auf das Südchinesische Meer
kann China somit auf die Unterstützung
von Lars und Kambodscha bauen damit
Asian nicht gegen die Interessen Chinas
handelt
china baut seine Präsenz im Indischen
Ozean rapide aus
ist klar dass China sich als Großmacht
zur See etablieren will wir streiten
nicht darüber denn
aufsteigende Mächte wie China zwingen
benachbarte Länder wie Indien oder
ehemals vorherrschende Wirtschaftsmächte
wie die USA dazu ihre Rolle zu
überdenken
sie sind besorgt wegen der Stärke Chinas
und der in meinen Augen durchaus
berechtigten engeren Anbindung Chinas an
den Rest der Welt
es geht um viel mehr als nur Handelswege
entlang der alten Seidenstraße
Globalisierung Vernetzung moderne
Transportmittel und Finanzen
die Finanzierung dieser Projekte ist
noch ungewiss
auch in Ländern wie Pakistan sind die
Details der Finanzierung dieser
Geschäfte noch unklar
es gibt bedenken dass die lokalen
Regierungen zu viel für chinesische
Verträge bezahlen
die ersten chinesischen Darlehen der
letzten Jahre gingen an Länder ohne
stabile Regierung wie Venezuela Sudan
Angola Iran Pakistan
Länder die durchaus Schuldenprobleme
bekommen könnten aber auch Länder wie
Indonesien Südafrika und ostafrikanische
Länder gehören zu den Gläubigern
china hat bessere und schlechtere
Klienten und in den besser verwalteten
Ländern sind durchaus Erfolge zu
erwarten
man fokussiert sich oft auf Geschäfte
von vor fünf Jahren die gerade fertig
werden wie Häfen und Schienennetze
wenn man sich aber tiefgreifend mit
diesen Projekten befasst und die
aktuellen Geschäfte betrachtet
unterscheiden sie sich überhaupt nicht
von den Plänen anderer großer Länder
dieser in Bezug auf die nächsten Jahre
besonders aufregen und vielversprechende
Aspekt wird oft übersehen
für Hafenbetreiber wie in Hongkong sind
die Chancen enorm es werden
handelszuwächse und bis zu zweieinhalb
Billionen Dollar in zehn Jahren erwartet
als nächstes erfahren wir die
Perspektive von mask und APM Terminals
zur neuen Seidenstraße
[Musik]
wir sind in China der ältesten der vier
großen alten Hauptstädte Chinas Heimat
der Hand Dynastie und der
Terrakotta-Armee am östlichen Ende der
alten Seidenstraße
[Musik]
den muslimischen Viertel skihan kann man
einen Blick in die Vergangenheit werfen
viele hier sind Nachfahren arabischer
Händler die monatelang auf der
Seidenstraße nach China reisten
das China als größte Handelsnation den
Welthandel fördern will überrascht wenig
die neue Seidenstraße dient ganz
offensichtlich auch dem Ziel das
Handelsvolumen um 2,5 Billionen Dollar
in zehn Jahren zu erhöhen
einige Projekte sind für uns als
Logistikanbieter sehr reizvoll
er Handelsvolumen bedeutet mehr Fracht
für unsere Schiffe mehr Umsatz in den
Häfen mehr Güter in den Lagerhäusern
wo sehen Sie in der Infrastruktur die
größten Lücken
man muss die Vernetzung weiter ausbauen
die Mischung zeigt dass bessere
Vernetzung der Transportwege die Kosten
des Handels verringert wodurch der
Handel wächst
eine 10-prozentige Verbesserung der
Vernetzung senkt die Kosten um drei
Prozent und erhöht das Volumen um 5 bis
9 Prozent
wir sehen eine direkte Verbindung dieser
zwei Faktoren
apm-terminals die Container
terminalsparte von mask betreibt 78
Häfen in 58 Ländern viele entlang der
alten Seidenstraße
einige unserer fortgeschrittenen
Projekte fallen in den Bereich der neuen
Seidenstraße
im italienischen wir gemeinsam mit cosco
und der Qingdao Port Group ein neues
Containerterminal
auch in Afrika richten wir gemeinsam mit
chinesischen Firmen neue Häfen wenn es
in unser beider Interesse liegt
Chancen für die Zusammenarbeit bieten
sich also nicht nur in Asien sondern
entlang der Gesam der neuen Seidenstraße
was sollte in den ersten Jahren der
neuen Seidenstraße unser Hauptaugenmerk
sein
wir würden uns Verbesserungen bei der
Transparenz erhoffen
oft erfahren wir erst von Projekten wenn
die beteiligten sich bereits geeinigt
haben
hier würden sich internationale Firmen
gerne mehr einbringen
das können wir auch bei der EU
beobachten auch dort gilt die
Verbesserung der Transparenz als
Schlüsselkomponente für den
langfristigen Erfolg der neuen
Seidenstraße
es gibt viele Hindernisse aber auch
ungeahnte Möglichkeiten wer wird
letztendlich am meisten von den
billionenausgaben für die neue
Seidenstraße profitieren
es geht zunehmend um stabilere Länder
und allgemeine Infrastrukturfinanzierung
Länder wie Brasilien Südafrika und
Ostafrika mit großem Bedarf an
Infrastruktur
sie sehen darin gewaltiges Potenzial die
Vorstellung der großen chinesischen
infrastrukturverschwörung ist einfach
unrealistisch
letztendlich ist gilt die treibende
Kraft
wenn chinesische Firmen zum Beispiel
fortschrittliche
schienenverkehrsprojekte in Indien
errichten können und indische Firmen das
als Chance wahrnehmen mit einer
Partnerschaft Geld zu verdienen werden
sie es tun
Geld wird weiterhin die treibende Kraft
sein
die Nachbarländer Chinas und die Länder
auf dem Weg von China nach Europa werden
als erste profitieren
Zentralasien und Südostasien
ich hoffe jedoch dass die Verbindung
nach Südasien insbesondere nach Indien
gestärkt wird denn das
indisch-chinesische Verhältnis ist wohl
das bedeutendste der Welt
außerdem hoffe ich dass Afrika stark
davon profitieren kann um zu großen
Wachstumsmärkten in Asien aufzuschließen
betonte in seiner monumentalen
Deklaration beim ersten Treffen zu dem
Thema die Verbindungen der neuen
Seidenstraßen zu bereits bestehenden
Initiativen die von anderen Ländern
hervorgebracht wurden
daher unterstützt die asiatische
Infrastruktur Investmentbank die
Initiative
denn Projekt der an uns herangetragen
werden müssen Sie natürlich unseren
Standards entsprechend
unsere drei grundlegenden Standards sind
finanzielle Nachhaltigkeit
Umweltschutz und der Schutz der
Interessen der Bevölkerung vor Ort
ab der Mitte des 15 jahrhunderts begann
aufgrund des effizienteren Handels zur
See sowie Streitigkeit inzwischen
Teilnehmer starten der Zerfall der
Seidenstraße zu der Zeit wurde auch die
verbotene Stadt hinter mir
fertiggestellt die für die folgenden 500
Jahre den chinesischen Kaiser
beherbergen sollte die Wiederbelebung
der Seidenstraße bezeugt Chinas erneuten
Aufstieg als globale Handelsmacht
[Musik]
Inas neu Seidenstraße ist unzweifelhaft
ein gewaltiges Projekt
Ausgaben in Billionenhöhe um China auf
der Straße der Schiene dem Wasser und
über Pipelines mit der Welt zu vernetzen
von China durch Zentralasien nach Europa
Afrika Nahost Südostasien und Indien
das ehrgeizige Projekt ist bereits sein
eigenes Ökosystem
Indien das Land steht der neuen
Seidenstraße jedoch alles andere als
offen gegenüber zwei gewaltige
Volkswirtschaften mit mehr als einem
Drittel der Weltbevölkerung und eine
langen Geschichte des wechselseitigen
misstrauenswand es ist nachvollziehbar
dass Indien wegen seines rapide
wachsenden Nachbarn der Indien an sich
bereits überholt hat beunruhigt ist und
nicht möchte dass China die gesamte
asiatische Infrastruktur plant
gleichzeitig könnte Indien von Chinas
Infrastrukturprojekten in der Region
profitieren
viele Länder die sich an Projekten der
neuen Seidenstraße beteiligen wie zum
Beispiel Sri Lanka drohen in eine
Schuldenfalle zu tappen
unsere Nachbarn Pakistan die Malediven
und Sri Lanka haben unsere Ansicht nach
ein besonders hohes Risiko der
Überschuldung
seit jeher wegen China und der geteilten
Grenze besorgt ebenso bezüglich Pakistan
sollten Sie also wegen der neuen
Seidenstraße besorgt sein sie werden
wohl besonders bei angrenzenden Ländern
die sie historisch beeinflussten besorgt
sein
da ist wegen der Eisenbahn nach Neapel
einem Hafen in Bangladesch oder Sri
Lanka oder dem Chinesisch pakistanischen
wirtschaftskorridor
[Musik]
also Kernpunkte Ablehnung Indiens ist
das größte Projekt der neuen
Seidenstraße
der Chinesisch pakistanische
wirtschaftskorridor der sich aus einer
der westlichsten Städte Chinas durch das
umkämpfte Kaschmir bis zum Arabischen
Meer zieht
der wirtschaftskorridor ist bisher die
größte einzelne Komponente der neuen
Seidenstraße und bedeutet Pakistan viel
China konnte in kurzer Zeit
beispielsweise den Mangel an Energie-
und Elektrizität den Pakistan lindern
Pakistan
viel ist aber auch für China wichtig
denn Pakistan ist seit langem mit China
verbündet
ein Widerpart zu Indien mit Zugang zum
Arabischen Meer an der Grenze zur
politisch brisanten chinesischen Provinz
der Erfolg bedeutet also beiden Parteien
viel
mache ich als Unternehmen eine viel
Investition muss ich das wegstecken und
weitermachen eine Regierung hat aber
nicht nur finanzielle Sorgen
beispielsweise vermietet seinen Hafen
der direkt neben Indien und an einer
großen internationalen frachtroute liegt
auch im pakistanischen Hafen von guada
wurde eine Milliarde investiert obwohl
der ebenfalls nicht aussichtsreich ist
so eigentlich man sichert sich also
heute diese frachthäfen die langfristig
jedoch auch anderen Zwecken dienen
können
ebenfalls viel Geld schuldet stellt dem
chinesischen Militär nur mehr einen Teil
des Landes für militärische Basen zur
Verfügung
das sind definitiv strategische
Interessen im Spiel
der Korridor durch Pakistan ist
wirtschaftlich nicht einleuchtend denn
er führt über den Himalaya von China
nach Pakistan nicht allzu praktisch
das wirkt wie ein strategisches Manöver
Chinas also verstehe ich warum sich
Indien umzingelt fühlt wenn China in
Motor in Pakistan einrichtet
das Schienennetz Indiens reicht
eineinhalb Mal um die Erde und befördert
offiziell 8 Milliarden Passagiere im
Jahr
dazu
die die gewaltige Nation inoffiziell
bereisen sind es noch viel mehr
zu Stoßzeiten drängen sich bis zu 7000
Fahrgäste in Züge die für 1.700
ausgelegt sind
das System ist veraltet und dringend
sanierungsbedürftig
die Stimmung in Indien wandelt sich es
winken große Investitionen seitens der
ai-ip beispielsweise in den Nahverkehr
in Mumbai wo wir gerade sind das ist nur
ein Beispiel für Zusammenarbeit
bezüglich der Infrastruktur
indienseidenstraße passieren können
dass ich Indiens Nachbarn allen voran
Sri Lanka Nepal und pakist mit so viel
Begeisterung an der neuen Seidenstraße
beteiligen liegt auch am Versagen
Indiens sich mit seinen Nachbarn zu
vernetzen
Indien betreibt aus historischen Gründen
kaum Handel mit Pakistan
konnte jedoch auch jahrzehntelang keine
bedeutsame infrastrukturverbindung nach
Nepal einrichten
auch nach Bangladesch gibt es kaum
Verbindungen weder für Energie noch für
den Warenverkehr das gleiche gilt auch
für Sri Lanka
[Musik]
war früher Teil der alten Seidenstraße
auf den Hafen welche der größte des
Landes ist empfehlt die Hälfte des
Containerverkehrs auch das westliche
Marinekommando Indiens ist hier ansässig
im Westen liegen das Arabische Meer
Pakistan und der Nahe Osten östlich
liegt der Reichtum Südostasiens und
etwas weiter China
[Musik]
kommen nicht überraschend man vergleicht
die Wirtschaftsleistung die
Investitionen und die Projekte
landen nur ein oder zwei Schiffe pro
Woche an kein Wunder dass das Projekt
scheiterte das gleiche könnte in guada
passieren auch hier wurde eine Milliarde
investiert
wenn die empfänger-nationen der neuen
Seidenstraße mit China angemessene
Konditionen aushandeln wollen gibt es
kaum Gegenangebote das war Chinas großer
Vorteil
sie bieten nicht nur die Finanzierung
sondern auch das Know-how wodurch sie
ein überzeugendes Gesamtpaket anbieten
die Empfängerländer müssen aber
bezüglich der Finanzierung aufpassen
so als nächstes begeben wir uns von
Indien nach Zentralasien und folgen
Chinas neuer Seidenstraße
kasachstan ist eines der Länder die am
meisten von der neuen Seidenstraße
profitieren könnten die Hauptstadt nur
Sultan ist das Verwaltungszentrum des
größten Binnenlands der Welt es liegt
zwischen Russland und China und ist der
Mittelpunkt eines geopolitischen wie
wirtschaftlichen balanceakts
[Musik]
die hochmoderne Stadt nur Sultan wurde
durch den Ölreichtum der vorherrschenden
Wirtschaft
Zentralasiens finanziert
City die Stadt feiert ihr 20-jähriges
Bestehen und den Geburtstag des bis 2019
einzigen Präsidenten
super
Präsident des Landes seit Kasachstan
1991 unabhängig wurde
hier eröffnet er nach fünf Jahren
Planung spektakulär nur Sultans
Finanzzentrum um die Kapitalmärkte der
Region zu vernetzen
genau wie das Land auch seine Rolle als
entscheidender binnenabschnitt der neuen
Seidenstraße akzeptiert hat
das Herzstück der Wirtschaftspolitik der
Regierung ist Diversifizierung die
Erschaffung neuer Wirtschaftszweige
sowohl in der Industrie als auch bei
Dienstleistungen insbesondere
Finanzdienstleistungen
der Region werden um die Wirtschaft in
der Region aufzubauen und sehen
Kasachstan in einer guten Position
dieses Ziel zu erreichen
wir sind das erste Land auf dem Weg von
China nach Europa und haben bereits
Infrastruktur aufgebaut bevor die neue
Seidenstraße ins Leben gerufen wurde die
2500 Kilometer Schienen verbinden den
Osten und den Westen des Landes was sich
seit Beginn der Initiative als
praktischer wies
wir waren vorbereitet und arbeiten nun
mit China an der Umsetzung verschiedener
Projekte
insgesamt sind in Kasachstan 58 Projekt
im Wert von 28 Milliarden Dollar geplant
sie sind Teil der neuen Seidenstraße
aber diene nicht nur dazu es ist eine
weitreichende wirtschaftliche
Partnerschaft
es ist für uns besonders von Vorteil da
wir ein Durchgangsland sind
damit lässt sich viel Geld verdienen
wir haben den 3000 Kilometer langen
kasachischen Teil des super Highway von
China nach Westeuropa fertiggestellt was
für die Strecke bis zur russischen
Grenze etwa 3 Milliarden Dollar gekostet
hat
ein anderer Weg führt zum Kaspischen
Meer wo wir in Kurt einen neuen Hafen
Bauten
der Weg führt über das Meer nach
Aserbaidschan und Georgien
von dort aus in die Türkei und zum
Mittelmeer und von dort aus weiter nach
Westen
ein weiterer Weg ist die Eisenbahn von
actao am Kaspischen Meer durch
Turkmenistan und Iran zum Persischen
Golf
wir haben also vielfältige Handelswege
eingerichtet und verschiedene
Alternativen parat
nach Norden Westen und auch nach Süden
und Koss an der Kasachisch chinesischen
Grenze ist der größte Umschlagplatz der
Welt in Planung er entsteht in der
kasachischen Steppe nicht weit vom
sogenannten eurasischen Punkte
Unzulänglichkeit entfernt denn am
weitesten vom nächsten Ozean entfernten
Punkt der Welt nahezu alles was von
China aus auf der Schiene nach Westen
gelangt nimmt diesen Weg
[Musik]
China trägt 50% der Kosten
jetzt können Züge aus dem Osten Chinas
zuerst China und dann Kasachstan
durchqueren und in nur zwei Wochen nach
Istanbul gelangen
to ist
und wir wollen diese Reisezeit noch
verringern
vielleicht zwölf oder zehn Tage
dieser Teil der Erde war
jahrhundertelang das Herz der
Seidenstraße
jetzt da die neue Seidenstraße mit
Schienen und Asphalt wieder aufgebaut
wird wird Kasachstan erneut das
entscheidende Drehkreuz in Eurasien sein
welche Branchen werden in Kasachstan
davon profitieren
die Seewege haben uns ein wenig das
rampenlich gestohlen doch so langsam
geraten Landwege wieder in den Blick
profitieren wird natürlich das Bauwesen
aber auch die Verarbeitung in der
Petrochemie deren Produkte für den
Straßenbau benötigt werden und auch die
Landwirtschaft und die
Lebensmittelbranche werden profitieren
das containervolumen das von China aus
Kasachstan durchquert hat sich in den
letzten sieben Jahren jährlich
verdoppelt die Schätzung für 2020 liegt
bei 2 Millionen Containern Kasachstan
erwartet also Transitgebühren in Höhe
von 5 Milliarden Dollar im Jahr
unweit des Umschlagplatzes liegt die von
China und Kasachstan so getaufte
internationale Freihandelszone die
Grenze wird auf beiden Seiten von der
strategisch geplanten Seidenstraßen
Zwillingsstadt flankiert die aktuell
jedoch noch ein Niemandsland ist
während des Kalten Krieges war das hier
ein militärisches Sperrgebiet die Türme
im Hintergrund markieren die Grenze
die chinesische Seite wurde fast
vollständig ausgebaut doch auch
kasachstan hat große Pläne um aufzuholen
Kongress ist das Tor zum chinesischen
Markt also beschlossen unsere
Regierungen die Einrichtung einer
Sonderwirtschaftszone um das
handelsdrehkreuz zu etablieren
war es ein Flaschenhals
nun bauen wir es aus um den Warenverkehr
in beide Richtungen zu verbessern
doch auch fünf Jahre nach Beginn der
Planungen ist zumindest die kasachische
Seite alles andere als fertig
[Musik]
manche halten Kasachstan für den Knoten
der die Seidenstraße zusammenhält es
gibt jedoch noch Probleme
wir haben die Infrastruktur ausgebaut
und in enger Zusammenarbeit mit unseren
Nachbarn wie Russland und Belarus die
eurasische Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
eingerichtet
somit konnten wir sowohl Zölle als auch
schienenverkehrsgebühren
vereinheitlichen und haben dadurch nicht
nur harte Infrastruktur in Form von
2.500 Kilometern Schienen erschaffen
sondern auch die weiche Infrastruktur
verbessert und handelshindernisse
abgebaut
[Musik]
vom zentralasiatischen Kasachstan geht
es nun nach Südostasien auf unserer
Reise entlang der neuen Seidenstraße
[Musik]
die neue Seidenstraße bietet den Ländern
von Asien gewaltige Chancen da
Infrastruktur der Schlüssel zum
Wirtschaftswachstum ist in Indonesien
den Philippinen Myanmar Laos Malaysia
und Thailand entstehen Projekte im Wert
von hunderten Milliarden Dollar um die
Vernetzung zu verbessern
wenn die physische Infrastruktur einmal
steht wirkt sich das positiv auf Handel
und Investitionen aus
this is one das ist ein zentrales
Element der wirtschaftlichen Zukunft
Indonesiens
ich bin sicher im kommenden Jahr wird
die Produktivitätssteigerung durch die
Infrastrukturprojekte unser
Wirtschaftswachstum antreiben
wir vergrößern unsere Flughäfen nicht
weil wir uns mehr Verkehr erhoffen
sondern weil sie bereits überfordert
sind
auch unsere Häfen sind überfüllt und wir
verbessern im Rahmen unserer Bauprojekte
ebenfalls unsere Straßen
zudem fördert das nicht nur die
Vernetzung innerhalb unseres Landes
sondern auch über die Landesgrenzen
hinaus
wie viele Nachbarstaaten investiert auch
Thailand in die neue Seidenstraße
mit Chinas Hilfe geben Sie Milliarden
aus um den Osten des Landes in einen
wirtschaftskorridor zu verwandeln und
weitere Milliarden für Projekte wie
diese Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke von
Bangkok nach China
der Mega Bahnhof wird Bangkoks Drehkreuz
für schnell Züge sein Richtung Norden
durch Laos nach China und Richtung Süden
durch Malaysia nach Singapur wobei
dieser Teil des Projekts in Gefahr ist
zudem werden so die drei größten
Flughäfen Thailands an den
wirtschaftskorridor im Osten angebunden
das Projekt soll nicht nur ein
Beschleuniger für die Vernetzung
innerhalb Thailands sondern auch mit
anderen insbesondere benachbarten
Ländern sein
im Norden liegt China also ist es nur
folgerichtig dass wir den Anschluss an
die neue Seidenstraße suchen
es wird ein durchgängiger Korridor der
von China im Norden nach Süden durch
Thailand und nach ganz Asien verläuft
jedes Land muss seine eigenen Interessen
waren und sicherstellen dass es sich die
Darlehen leisten kann
nicht nur jetzt sondern auch für
zukünftige Generationen
unsere zwei Darlehen sind eines in Höhe
von 62,5 Millionen Dollar für einen Damm
und eines für die städtische
Wasserversorgung in Höhe von 200
Millionen Dollar
aktuell handeln wir ein größeres
Darlehen in Höhe von etwa 2,8 Milliarden
Dollar für ein Eisenbahnprojekt
ausgehen es dient der Verbesserung
bestehender Bahninfrastruktur die in
schlechtem Zustand ist
in Indonesien haben wir bereits ein
System für wichtige
Infrastrukturprojekte eingerichtet
anhand dessen entscheiden wir dann
welche Projekte wir gerne in die neue
Seidenstraße eingliedern würden
die Umsetzung ist das größte Problem out
of the fifty von den angepeilten 50
konnten wir bisher erst 9 Projekte
umsetzen wir haben also noch viel vor
uns
die Finanzierung steht auch wenn einige
Anforderungen erfüllen müssen um sie zu
erhalten
unüberschaubare Kosten
nicht nur bei der neuen Seidenstraße
Indonesien durchläuft gerade Reformen
und viele Infrastrukturprojekte haben
regulatorische Probleme
Lizenzen Arbeitskräfte auch beim Land
Erwerb gibt es Probleme
wir müssen eine Vielzahl lokaler
Probleme lösen um größtmögliche Gewinne
zu realisieren
[Musik]
für China führt ein weiterer bedeutender
Abschnitt durch Myanmar wo lokale
Probleme viele Fragen aufwerfen
das Land grenzt an China Indien und
Bangladesch und bietet nicht nur eine
Route zum Indischen Ozean sondern auch
über Land zum Westen des indischen
Subkontinents
es gibt in vielerlei Hinsicht Bedenken
große Infrastrukturprojekte häufen große
Schulden an die Regierung ist wegen der
Überschuldung des Landes besorgt die die
nächste Generation treffen könnte
das ist etwas Gutes denn so bauen wir
nicht einfach auf Gedeih und Verderb
ohne unser Budget zu bedenken
nach Jahren unter militärische
Herrschaft ist Myanmars Infrastruktur
dringend reformbedürftig und somit ein
ideales Ziel der neuen Seidenstraße
wie sich die Projekte auf das technische
Know-how und die Arbeitskräfte im Land
auswirken werden
an forschen von Chinas langjähriger
Unterstützung Mia Mars bekam die
Bevölkerung in der Vergangenheit in
vielen Fällen kaum positive Effekte mit
willkommen in Mombasa seit Jahrhunderten
kommen Händler aus Arabien Portugal
Großbritannien und Indien auf der Suche
nach Reichtum und Glück in die älteste
Stadt Kenias
wir werden nun betrachten ob die
aktuellen Interessen Chinas sich mit
denen des afrikanischen Kontinents
überschneiden
gilt als das Tor nach Ostafrika
mindestens fünf Binnenländer wie Uganda
und Ruanda sind auf diesen Hafen
angewiesen die Bahnstrecke Mombasa
Nairobi auch SGR genannt ist das größte
Infrastrukturprojekt deshalb 1963
unabhängigen Landes
Kenia bezahlte 3,8 Milliarden Dollar
China riegelte die Finanzierung und
baute den Anfang eine Schienennetzes das
den Verkehr von Waren und Fahrgästen bis
ins Herz des Kontinents ermöglichen soll
die SGA verkürzt die Reise im Kenias
Hauptstadt von über acht Stunden mit dem
Laster auf 5 Stunden
ich glaube die neue Seidenstraße wird
der Region gut tun
die railway Link ich habe zwar Bedenken
wegen des Preises der für die
Bahnstrecke Mombasa Nairobi bezahlt
wurde aber dass wir diese
Bahnverbindungen haben eröffnet uns
gewaltige Chancen immens
opportunities sie beschleunigt den
Warenverkehr und verbessert die
Versorgung und das ist überaus
wünschenswert
niemand kann es mit Chinas Infrastruktur
Investitionen aufnehmen aus unserer
kenianischen Perspektive sind
Infrastrukturinvestitionen allerdings
immer willkommen ob sie nun aus Amerika
China oder Europa stammen denn mit ihrer
Hilfe werden wir wettbewerbsfähig der
Markt ist da aber die Vernetzung für den
warntransport ist das Problem so wir
hoffen dass die neue Seidenstraße diese
Märkte mit allen am Projekt beteiligten
Ländern verknüpft
bessere Transportwege sind für den
Ausbau der Region unerlässlich der IWF
rechnete für das Jahr 2019 für Ostafrika
mit einem Wachstum von
6,2%. der Hafen von Mombasa wird zu
diesem Zweck ausgebaut der Hafen
bewältigte 2018 ein Volumen von 1,2
Millionen Containern das soll jährlich
um drei bis fünf Prozent wachsen
das wirtschaftliche Potenzial ist
offensichtlich doch die Umsetzung sorgt
für Probleme zwar erreichen die
Container die Hauptstadt schneller doch
dort erscheinen mit den Rechnungen in
die Probleme
die Regierung verspricht jedoch dass es
keine teure Fehlinvestition sein wird
diese Druckerpressen produzieren
Milliarden Etiketten im Jahr die manchen
supermarktbesuchern überraschend
vertraut sein dürften
jeden Tag sieben Güterzüge mit je 150
Containern aus Mombasa nach Nairobi
insgesamt fast 800 Container am Tag
früher lief das über eine einspurige
Straße und führte zu gewaltigen Staus
und sogar Todesfällen
Kenia hat jedoch den Flaschenhals an der
containerverladestation in Nairobi noch
nicht gelöst
diese quillt vor Containern über
der Stau in Nairobi ist schlecht fürs
Geschäft
nutzen Sie ihn ja
obwohl er teurer ist die Regierung
zwingt uns beinahe dazu
Logistik hat immer mehrere Komponenten
zunächst geht es von Mombasa nach Ruanda
und dann weiter nach Westafrika aktuell
gibt es keine Strecke nach Westafrika
das könnte man einfach ausbauen
es geht aber auch um den Rückweg von
Kigali über Mombasa nach China diese
zwei wege-logistik ist wichtig für den
Wettbewerb
das ist so unsere Länder brauchen das um
zu exportieren und ihrerseits
wettbewerbsfähig zu werden
bitco ist Ostafrikas größter Hersteller
von Speiseölen Reinigungsmitteln und
anderen Verbrauchsgütern Fabriken in
Kenia Uganda Tansania und Madagaskar
beliefern 18 Länder in der Region der
Präsident des Unternehmens ist
vorsichtig optimistisch bezüglich der
Investitionen Chinas es gibt keinen
Zweifel daran dass China mehr Handel
betreiben möchte
durch ihre wirtschaftliche Dominanz
haben sie heutzutage einen
Wettbewerbsvorteil wenn Sie also Ihre
Industrie hierher verlagern um für den
Westen zu produzieren wird Afrika nicht
vers den Arbeitsplätze
sind sie besorgt über die
Aufrechterhaltung dieser
Vormachtstellung
machen wir uns deswegen keine Sorgen
denn für unsere Waren ist China ein
potentieller Absatzmarkt guten Morgen
China und Indien werden viel mehr
Nahrungsmittel und andere waren für ihre
gewaltigen Bevölkerung brauchen hier
kommt Afrika ins Spiel wir müssen also
betrachten was wir aus Afrika über die
neuseidenstraße nach China exportieren
können
wie viel verkaufen sie aktuell an China
und Indien
gar nichts
diese optimistischen Einstellung stehen
Ängste entgegen China würde die horrent
teure Infrastruktur nur benutzen um
schnell neue Märkte auszunutzen und die
Länder Afrikas hoch verschuldet
zurücklassen auch gibt es Bedenken
bezüglich der Transparenz die China road
and bridge Corporation erhielt den
Zuschlag die Strecke 10 Jahre lang zu
betreiben ohne Ausschreibung
Chinas Unternehmungen in Afrika zielen
auf den Handel ab nicht Wohltätigkeit
auch sind sie Zeugnis des Selbstbildes
der Zukunft des Landes nicht nur in
politischer Hinsicht
Kenia und seine Nachbarstaaten sehen es
als Wachstumsmotor obwohl die
langfristige Perspektive unklar ist es
gibt Zweifel wegen der Verschuldung und
ob tatsächlich beide Seiten profitieren
würden
betrachten wir als nächstes ob das eine
Möglichkeit ist oder nur eine Seite
siegen kann
die Hälfte der Container in Mombasa
landen hier in Nairobi doch das ist
nicht das Ende der Geschichte die Chance
zur Erschließung neuer Märkte geht weit
über die Hauptstadt und die Grenzen
Kenias hinaus nach Tansania Uganda
Ruanda und Europa die Frage ist ob der
Preis am Ende zu hoch sein wird
unsere Anführer geben Afrika an China ab
wir müssen das richtige Maß finden und
gleichzeitig unser Land erhalten
wir können viel von China lernen und
profitieren aber es muss Grenzen geben
wir dürfen China nicht unser Land
übernehmen lassen
[Musik]
wir mischen uns nicht in innere
Angelegenheiten afrikanischer Länder ein
zwingen ihnen nicht unseren Willen auf
knüpfen Wirtschaftshilfen nicht an
politische Bedingungen und verfolgen bei
der Zusammenarbeit mit und den
Investitionen in Afrika keine
eigennützigen politischen Ziele
China wehrt sich gegen Vorwürfe die neue
Seidenstraße führe zu Überschuldung der
Partnerstaaten und widerspricht der
Ansicht Peking würde seinen politischen
Einfluss ausbauen wollen Chinas
Präsident beteuert es sei ein Werkzeug
für gemeinsamen Wohlstand
Afrika hat zwar großen Bedarf an
Infrastruktur doch die Schulden des
Kontinents wachsen erheblich
2015 verließ China laut der China
African research Initiative 12
Milliarden Dollar an Afrika verglichen
mit nur 100 Millionen im Jahr 2000 nicht
zuletzt beteiligten sich chinesische
Firmen viele davon in staatlicher Hand
an Infrastrukturprojekten in Afrika oft
mit Hilfe der chinesischen Export
importbank Exem einem staatlichen
politisch motivierten Kreditgeber die
SGA von Mombasa nach Nairobi wurde zu
90% über ein solches Darlehen finanziert
in Anbetracht des warenvolumens sowie
der konstruktions- und Betriebskosten
sowie der Darlehen kann sich die SGA
niemals selbst finanzieren
wir müssen den Kredit aber so oder so
zurückzahlen also werden Steuereinnahmen
aus anderen Bereichen herangezogen um
die Schulden zu begleichen
der nächste Streckenabschnitt wird mit
einem Kredit über 1,5 Milliarden Dollar
von der exim-bank finanziert der Ausbau
nach kisumo wird 3,6 Milliarden Dollar
kosten die Kenia nun gerne als Zuschuss
von China bekäme nicht als Kredit der
Anschluss nach Uganda wird weitere 4,9
Milliarden Dollar verschlingen
Kritiker der neuen Seidenstraße
behaupten die Länder würden ihre Zukunft
verpfänden und sich hoch verschulden
bankrott gehen und letztlich die
Kontrolle ihrer Wirtschaft an China
verlieren
ich glaube nicht dass es dazu kommt
man redet oft von Diplomatie über
Schuldenfallen als Manöver Chinas sich
strategische Werte zu sichern
ein Militärstützpunkt könnte ich China
im Falle einer Pleite chemias durch die
Bahnstrecke den Hafen von Mombasa
übernehmen
ich halte das für unwahrscheinlich denn
die Handels- und investitionsvorteile
die durch die Projekte entstehen wiegen
deutlich schwerer als solche Interessen
natürlich Zahlen Länder auf zu viel für
Infrastruktur
aber in diesem Fall war die
Infrastruktur erforderlich und wird sich
auf lange Sicht positiv auf die
Wirtschaft auswirken
Infrastrukturunternehmen wie die China
communications construction company
deren Tochtergesellschaft die SGA
betreibt sehen es als Chance sowohl ihr
eigenes wachst als auch das afrikanische
Staaten zu fördern
ganz Afrika hat großes
Entwicklungspotenzial der Arbeitsmarkt
ist groß und jung aber wegen des
schwachen Wirtschaftswachstums gibt es
wenig gute Jobangebote China war in den
1970er Jahren in der gleichen Lage und
wir denken Afrika wird ebenfalls die
Chancen für die Entwicklung ergreifen
wollen
der Zustrom chinesischer Firmen und
Arbeiter befeuert jedoch Vorwürfe das
Wohlstand und Chancen nicht vor Ort
ankommen
die Finanzierung der Projekte kommt von
chinesischen Banken die Aufträge gehen
an chinesische Bauunternehmen die ganzen
großen Milliardenbeträge fließen also an
chinesische Firmen
auch Transparenz und Korruption sind ein
Problem
das ist eine gewaltige Debatte können
wir die Verschuldung gegenüber China
bewältigen oder Verschulden wir uns zu
hoch und geben letztendlich die
Kontrolle über das Land an China ab
es sollte hierbei eigentlich keine
garantienseitens der Regierung geben
alles sollte allein in private Hand
liegen vom Aufbau bis zum Betrieb und am
Ende sollte es zu einem fairen Preis den
Besitzer wechseln und dadurch Gewinn
erzeugen Luca man muss beides beachten
kurzfristige Einschnitte und
langfristige Gewinne
Kenias Bürger tragen jetzt gerade eine
große Steuerlast Taxis denn wir wollen
die Kredite bezahlen und trotzdem noch
weitere aufnehmen
wir müssen abwarten
unglücklicherweise ist Korruption ein
Problem in diesem Land wodurch
Ressourcen umgeleitet wurden
ein groß Projekt eine Hoffnung für das
Land werden
hoping doch es wird immer klarer das ist
die Erwartungen nicht erfüllen wird
bei der SRG gibt es immer noch viele
offene Fragen beispielsweise bezüglich
abgeschlossener Verträge
die Zahlungsmodalitäten sind klar ob
aber die Gesamtkosten aller einzelnen
Bestandteile Geräte und Baustellen
korrekt aufsummiert und zusammengezählt
wurden ist noch nicht geklärt und also
es ist nicht ausreichend transparent für
ein Projekt das 5% unserer
Wirtschaftsleistung verschlingt
die Frage ist ob die Kredite richtig und
für die richtigen Projekte mit den
richtigen gewinnen für die Länder
Afrikas genutzt werden
letztendlich müssen die afrikanischen
Staaten ihre eigene ganzheitliche
Perspektive entwickeln und nicht nur auf
Projektbasis arbeiten
und welche Infrastruktur brauchen wir
welche Projekte wie finanzieren wir das
am besten dann können Sie sich mit
verschiedenen Partnern bezüglich der
Umsetzung auseinandersetzen ob nun mit
China oder der Weltbank
früher ging es um Entwicklungshilfe und
wir entwickelten eine Abhängigkeit von
der Hilfe
[Musik]
I don't take das uns jemand betrogen
hätte wäre eine zu einfache Ausrede wir
müssen uns unsere Fehler eingestehen
[Musik]
es ist ein einseitiges Geschäft und die
Beteiligten chinesischen Firmen sind die
Gewinner die gut daran verdienen
abseits von moralischen Fragen haben sie
jedoch einfach besser verhandelt also
deshalb sollten wir Steuerzahler Kenias
unsere Regierung zur Rede stellen wie
sie sehenden Auges so einem Handel
zustimmen konnte
auch kenianische Firmen würden gerne
profitieren doch dies wird oft vereitelt
wie Export viele unsere
landwirtschaftlichen Produkte werden
nach Europa exportiert wenn der
chinesische Markt verschlossen bleibt
die Regierung könnte Verträge
unterzeichnen damit wir dorthin liefern
und wachsen könnten aber das ist noch
nicht geschehen
unsere Fertigungskapazitäten sind nicht
ausgelastet da wir noch nicht
wettbewerbsfähig sind
dafür werden Hilfe seitens der Regierung
erforderlich Prozess secondly die
außerdem gibt es keine Handelsabkommen
mit China die uns einen Vorteil
verschaffen würden
gleichzeitig sehen Kenias
fertigungsbranche und Regierung die
chinesischen Firmen als Chance
wir begrüßen die chinesischen Hersteller
in unserer fertigungsbranche
sie ist eines der vier Hauptziele der
Regierung und wir müssen möglichst viele
Investitionen sichern sowohl aus dem
Inland wie auch aus dem Ausland um uns
als Fertigungsstandort zu etablieren
Präsident Uhu Kenyatta will den Anteil
der Fertigung am Bruttoinlandsprodukt
bis 2022 auf 15% anheben auch
Landwirtschaft Gesundheitswesen und
Bauwesen sollen wachsen
die Fertigung alleine erschafft
zunehmend tausende Arbeitsplätze die auf
dem ganzen Kontinent dringend benötigt
werden
numbers die Innovationen die aus China
nach Afrika kommen werden oft simpel
aber wo China Afrika als wichtigen Markt
erachtet übernehmen sie die Erneuerung
für uns
der Vorsitzende von bitco sieht Chancen
für lokale Unternehmen wenn Afrika an
einem Strang zieht viele sehen die neue
Seidenstraße als Einbahnstraße obwohl
man doch auch auf den chinesischen
Marktwert ist das erreichbar
wir müssen die Produktivität in Afrika
steigern mehr Güter herstellen die einen
Mehrwert bieten und so Erfolg finden
das ist das Ziel aber klappt das
es ist an uns in Afrika dafür zu sorgen
wir müssen es richtig anstellen und
wettbewerbsfähig werden der Handel
innerhalb Afrikas ist geringer denn je
und es entstehen immer mehr
Handelsbarrieren
gleichzeitig ersparen wir China Amerika
und Europa Einfuhrzölle wir müssen
Afrikas Regierungen Vereinen und den
ewigen Debatten und Unterhaltungen Taten
folgen lassen
wir müssen es selbst in die Tat umsetzen
die afrika-politik Chinas hat sich
gewandelt und differenziert nun stärker
zwischen offizielle Außenpolitik und
Privatwirtschaft
2018 wurde eine entwicklungsbehörde
eingerichtet die die schwindende
Bedeutung der exenbank kompensieren soll
ein häufiger Kritikpunkt ist dass China
diese Kredite bewerben würde
dabei verlangen die afrikanischen
Staaten danach
China verfolgt eine Idealvorstellung
dieser Beziehung aber sie wollen sicher
nicht die Zukunft Afrikas gestalten
das schließt jedoch nicht aus das
wirtschaftliche Interessen bei Krediten
eine Rolle spielen
manchen zufolge geht es immer noch um
den Zugang zu Ressourcen
chinesische Firmen finden in Afrika
gewaltige Chancen vor die Sie im Rahmen
der neuen Seidenstraße auch nutzen
können
China sieht gewaltiges
Investitionspotenzial aber wie sieht es
für private und gewerbliche Investoren
aus
man kann nicht direkt in die neue
Seidenstraße investieren
man kann höchstens in ein sammelprojekt
afrikanischer und internationaler Firmen
investieren
wenn sich die Bedingungen ändern und
beispielsweise Energiepreise fallen wird
die Herstellung einfacher und rentabel
das Hauptargument Kenias und ganz
Ostafrikas ist allerdings der Zugang
wenn auch nicht unbedingt zu
Bodenschätzen oder natürlichen
Ressourcen
für uns ist es ein Tor zum Rest von
Afrika
langfristig entstehen neue Städte
beteiligen sich mehr Menschen an Handel
und Warenverkehr
zumindest wird das industrielle Zentrum
des Landes von Nairobi Weg in andere
Teile des Landes verlagert sobald das
geplante Industriezentrum in neuwasser
fertig ist kann die Herstellung und der
direkte Export der wahren von dort aus
nach Mombasa beginnen
bleiben noch die Bedenken chinesische
Firmen würden sich große Aufträge in
Afrika sichern so wie die Bedenken des
Weißen Hauses um den Einfluss der USA
sagen dass China bei der Umsetzung die
Nase vorn hat
Europa hatte 50 60 Jahre lang Zeit
Afrika zu helfen hat aber nicht viel
erreicht die Amerika hat Afrika einfach
ignoriert
china hat in kurzer Zeit viel bewegt
bessere Infrastruktur zu günstigeren
Preisen eingerichtet
gebundene Entwicklungshilfe gehört der
Vergangenheit an jetzt wird gehandelt
man kann es wirtschaftliche Dominanz
oder Kolonialisierung nennen aber a
braucht die Infrastruktur jetzt und
nicht später
Entwicklungshilfe kommt nie am Ziel an
richtig
zumindest selten
früher ging es um Entwicklungshilfe und
wir entwickelten eine Abhängigkeit von
der Hilfe okay das wollen wir aber nicht
wir wollen wettbewerbs- und
geschäftsfähig sein
aber es muss alles korrekt und
nachvollziehbar stattfinden und es darf
kein Geld zweckentfremdet werden
beide Seiten spielen mit hohem Einsatz
China sieht lukrative neue Märkte doch
wie erschließt man sie ohne als
Kolonialherr aufzutreten
den Empfänger starten winkt Generationen
übergreifender Wandel
China ist zwar ein Partner aber auch ein
Konkurrent
Fabriken wie diese können mit
effizienten chinesischen Betrieben
mithalten was aber nicht die Regel ist
viele mussten bereits klein beigeben
letztlich muss Afrika entscheiden
der alt ehrwürdige Hafen von Piräus
könnte demnächst der wichtigste Hafner
Mittelmeer und in ganz Europa werden
denn er nimmt eine Schlüsselrolle in
Chinas neue Seidenstraße ein die von
Griechenland nach Deutschland Brüssel
und London verlaufen wird wir beleuchten
die europäische Komponente der
chinesischen Pläne
Score ist eines der größten
Frachtunternehmen der Welt und somit ein
wichtiger Bestandteil der neuen
Seidenstraße
einen Drachenkopf eine strategische
Verbindung von Land und seeroben
das Unternehmen cosco übernahm 2009 für
35 Jahre die Verwaltung von Pier 2 und
investierte Millionen in die
Infrastruktur und einen dritten Bier
2016 verkaufte das schuldengebeutete
Griechenland eine Kontrollmehrheit der
Hafenbehörde an cosco
für 370 Millionen Euro und das
Versprechen weiterer Investitionen in
ähnlicher Höhe sicherte cosco die
Stellung von Piräus in Chinas neuer
Weltordnung der Hafen wurde ein Erfolg
cosco war zur rechten Zeit am rechten
Ort
2017 wurden in Piräus 4 Millionen
Container abgefertigt wodurch der Hafen
mehr auf Platz drei und in ganz Europa
auf Platz sieben landete
ein Wachstum von fast 200% verglichen
mit dem vorigen Jahrzehnt
dem Geschäftsführer des Hafens zufolge
war das kein einfacher Weg
es ist eine knallharte Branche jeder
gibt alles um zu
gewinnenstraße zwar durchaus aber eben
nicht finanziell
die neue Seidenstraße Chinas eröffnet
uns vielmehr neue Handelsmöglichkeiten
von denen wir als Hafenbetreiber
natürlich profitieren
diese Handelsmöglichkeiten sind für uns
als Hafenbetreiber der Ware nutzen
Chinas Investitionen haben dem Hafen von
Piräus geholfen doch es gibt bedenken
dass Chinas Einfluss lokale Unternehmen
verdrängen könnte
fast alle Firmen in Griechenland sind
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
sie machen sich Sorgen dass die riesigen
Unternehmen Ihnen das Geschäft streitig
machen könnten
die anfängliche Feindseligkeit wie ich
jedoch der Akzeptanz auf der Jagd nach
geschäftsschancen
viele sind unzufrieden denn sie sind der
Meinung wir könnten den Hafen auch
selbst nutzen
sie werfen China vor die griechische
Schuldenkrise ausgenutzt zu haben
andererseits gebietet es der
Geschäftssinn ein gutes Angebot zu einem
guten Preis anzunehmen
und eine Chance für uns alle über
Investitionen in den Hafen von Piräus zu
verhandeln
die Lieferketten liegen schließlich im
Hinterland wo wir uns einbringen und
investieren können
wo wir unsere Mittel effektiv nutzen
können um Anreize und Wachstum zu
erschaffen
und so die Wertschöpfung zu starten
der Aufstieg chinesischer Firmen in
Europa im Rahmen der neuen Seidenstraße
befeuert auch
Ängste vor Chinas geopolitischen und
sogenannten softpower Ambitionen
staatliche chinesische Firmen
kontrollieren dem Weltverkehrsforum
zufolge etwa 10% der Containerterminal
Kapazitäten in Europa die Europäische
Kommission begrüßt die neue Seidenstraße
unter Vorbehalt
es gibt zwei Hauptmerkmale die diese
Projekte erfüllen müssen
alle Projekte die von China und anderen
finanziert werden müssen wirtschaftlich
wie ökologisch nachhaltig sein
zudem müssen offene Ausschreibungen
erfolgen und eingehalten werden
wir nehmen gerne an dem Projekt teil
Projekt doch die Investitionen müssen
vernünftig sein most be reasable auch
über die Implementierung der
Investitionen hinaus gibt es Bedenken
die EU ist besorgt china könnte Europa
mit Hilfe der neuen Seidenstraße teilen
und erobern wollen
es gibt Länder in Mittel Süd- und
Osteuropa die sich noch nicht wie viele
andere von der Weltwirtschaftskrise
erholen konnten
daher würden Sie die Angebote Chinas für
Unterstützung und
Infrastrukturentwicklung gerne annehmen
diese Länder sind also empfänglich dafür
die Vorzüge der neuen Seidenstraße in
Anspruch zu nehmen und im Austausch
dafür auch in anderen Bereichen und
politischen Sphären China zu
unterstützen
das ist der Grund warum sich viele
europäische Staats- und Regierungschefs
Sorgen machen
in Bereichen wo Beschlüsse einstimmig
gefasst werden müssen reicht es China
eines der 28
berechtigten EU-Länder in der Hand zu
haben um Resolutionen in vielen
Bereichen effektiv aufhalten zu können
was sagen sie jenen die sich Sorgen
wegen der engen Zusammenarbeit
Griechenlands mit chinesischen Firmen
wie cosco machen da das zu
Abhängigkeiten führen könnte
Griechenland braucht die Investitionen
aus dem Ausland
Investitionen aus China sind uns daher
ebenso willkommen wie Investitionen aus
Deutschland oder den USA
[Musik]
von Siemens in Deutschland erklärt uns
warum es noch gefährlicher wäre die neue
Seidenstraße zu ignorieren eine
Initiative ob nun moralisch richtig oder
falsch von der 70% der Weltbevölkerung
betroffen sind muss man ernst nehmen
[Musik]
Piräus ist Chinas größte sie-anbindung
nach Europa Duisburg hingegen steht als
einer der größten Binnenhäfen der Welt
im Mittelpunkt von Chinas Ambitionen zu
Lande jede Woche kommen hier Züge voller
chinesischen Waren an von Spielzeug über
Kleidung des Elektronik die so über ein
europaweites Transportnetz zum
Verbraucher gelangen
durch die Vernetzung von Schiene und
Wasserstraße wurde Duisburg ein
Knotenpunkt der Industrie
historisch liegen die Wurzeln des Hafens
bei Kohle und Stahl da diese Branchen im
Abschwung sind sucht die Hafenleitung
Duisburg den Anschluss an die neue
Seidenstraße
am Anfang stand eine Schienenverbindung
zum Werk von HP im südwestchinesischen
Chongqing
vor 6 oder 7 Jahren an der erste Zug kam
direkt von Hewlett Packard nach Duisburg
als Drehscheibe zu etablieren und
Duisburg zur zentralen Anlaufstelle für
den wechselseitigen Handel zwischen
China und Europa zu machen
international studies hat die neue
Seidenstraße den schienengebundenen
Warenverkehr zwischen Europa und China
massiv gesteigert ebenso wie das Angebot
an güterverkehrsdiensten jede Woche
kommen etwa 30 Züge aus China in
Duisburg an China wollte die Menge bis
2020 auf 50 erhöhen und die Reisezeit
verringern momentan braucht ein Zug von
China nach Deutschland 12 Tage geplant
sind jetzt zehn Tage oder weniger
dank der produktionsteigerung im
Südwesten Chinas ist eine schnelle
Verbindung nach Europa wichtiger denn je
Städte wie Chongqing und Ching du liegen
fernab maritime Handelsrouten
zeitgleich sucht Duisburg die
Partnerschaft mit Projekten der neuen
Seidenstraße um das Geschäft auszubauen
und Geld in die Kasse der Stadt zu
spielen
wir haben eine Partnerschaft mit China
Mertens geschlossen und stehen kurz vor
einer strategischen Partnerschaft mit
Kasko
sie alle verfolgen klare Ziele und eine
Beteiligung hier in Duisburg ist
definitiv ein Teil dieser strategischen
Partnerschaften
eröffnet Ihnen die Partnerschaft mit
chinesischen Firmen Chancen in ganz
Europa
wir haben Kunden auf der ganzen Welt wir
müssen vorhersehen wo neue Handelswege
entstehen werden oder wie wir bestehende
verbessern können optimal
investieren wir gemeinsam mit dem
größten Logistikkonzern in der Türkei
der arcas-gruppe um einen rail-port nach
Istanbul zu errichten
darum wollen wir auch in einen railport
in Triest investieren
der neuen Seidenstraße werden wird
er kann dann ganz Südeuropa beliefern
der deutschen Industrie- und
Handelskammer zufolge sehen viele
Mitglieder indirekte Vorteile durch die
verbesserte Logistik der neuen
Seidenstraße
project nur ein knappes Drittel glaubt
jedoch sie könnten aktuell direkt
profitieren zudem haben viele Vorbehalte
und sind vorsichtig
nur einige wenige bedeutsame Akteure
sind aktuell tatsächlich beteiligt
Menschen zudem komme ich nicht umhin auf
Beschwerden bezüglich der
ausschreibungsprozesse zu verweisen
da diese aktuell noch nicht an einem
Punkt sind an dem wir sie als
transparent inklusiv fair bezeichnen
könnten
sie entsprechen noch nicht den
erwarteten gründlichen Standards für
öffentliche Ausschreibungen
denn China wird nicht müde zu betonen
die Initiative stünde allen offen und
wäre transparent was jedoch wohl nicht
den Tatsachen entspricht
wir wissen nicht wo die nächsten
Projekte entstehen werden
und wo wet über sich wie einbringen
können
sich deutsche und europäische Firmen
stärker beteiligen sollen brauchen wir
mehr Transparenz und müssen das alle am
gleichen Tisch besprechen
in order to discuss Siemens siemens ist
ein großes deutsches Unternehmen das
sich an der Initiative beteiligt und
2017 über sieben Milliarden Euro Umsatz
in China erzielen konnte 9 Prozent des
Gesamtumsatzes jetzt will es die
Partnerschaft vertiefen und wie dispoint
neue Wachstumsmöglichkeiten erschließen
aufgrund der Energiewende hatte das
einstige Flaggschiff des Unternehmens
die kraftwerksparte einen langfristigen
Rückgang verzeichnet
wir müssen also einen Strukturwandel
meistern das tun wir durch Innovationen
aber auch durch die Erschließung neuer
Geschäftsmöglichkeiten wie der neuen
Seidenstraße
beteiligt und den meisten davon vielen
nachhaltige und erschwingliche
Energiequellen das sehen wir als Chance
es werden oft Bedenken geäußert die
chinesischen Firmen mit denen sie
zusammenarbeiten hätten nicht die
gleichen Standards der
Unternehmensführung wäre nicht
transparent und anfällig für Korruption
setzen sie sich einem Risiko aus und ist
es diesen Preis vielleicht sogar Wert
den Preis werden wir nicht zahlen das
ist ein No-Go
wie in jeder Volkswirtschaft in jedem
Land muss sich China an internationale
Standards halten wenn Sie eine
internationale Rolle einnehmen wollen
was offenkundig ihr Ziel ist
wenn Ihnen dafür die Erfahrung fehlt ist
Siemens der ideale Partner denn wir
haben das auf die harte Tour gelernt und
wissen jetzt wie es geht
ist China Konkurrent oder Partner der
europäischen Wirtschaft beides in der
modernen Welt ist man nicht mehr
entweder Konkurrent oder Partner
je nachdem was man zu einem Projekt
beitragen kann ist man für verschiedene
Parteien beides
china plant seit jeher langfristig ich
glaube daher dass der Westen sich
zusammenreißen muss vernünftigen freien
Handel implementieren und Probleme lösen
muss
sonst sagt China irgendwann wir haben 90
Länder mit 70% der Weltbevölkerung in
der neuen Seidenstraße versammelt und
erklären diese nun zur neuen
Welthandelsorganisation haben
göttliche und politische
machtverlagerungen hängen oft von
Bevölkerungszahlen ab
eine Initiative ob nun moralisch richtig
oder falsch von der 70% der
Weltbevölkerung betroffen sind muss man
ernst nehmen
wenn es eine europäischen Firma gelingt
mit der neuen Seidenstraße Gewinn zu
machen dann Siemens Infrastruktur ist
Teil der Firma und sie hat bereits
starke Verbindungen nach China
der Erfolg hängt jedoch auch davon ab ob
westliche Staats- und Regierungschefs
China überzeugen können sich an
westliche geschäftsstandards zu halten
das ist unser nächstes Thema
[Musik]
für Männer viele Länder und Unternehmen
sehen die neue Seidenstraße als
Wachstumschance
zeitgleich ebnet sie chinesischen Firmen
den Weg
es zeigt sich jedoch dass es erheblichen
Widerstand im Gefüge Deutschlands
Frankreichs und der ganzen Europäischen
Union gibt
dank der Schuldenkrise Griechenlands
konnte China über Piräus den Seeweg nach
Europa vollenden
europäische Gesetzgeber zu überzeugen
erweist sich jedoch als schwierig als
die neue Seidenstraße 2013 angekündigt
wurde gab es viel Zuspruch aus Europa
europäische Staaten erhofften sich
Vorteile davon
2017 schwand diese Begeisterung jedoch
größtenteils wieder
die Haltung der EU ist das China
jederzeit willkommen ist das sehen wir
bei manchen Mitgliedstaaten ganz
besonders stark
aber es muss zu unseren oder zumindest
unter transparenten Bedingungen
geschehen
diese Voraussetzungen erfüllen die
meisten chinesischen Projekte die nicht
von der aiib finanziert werden aktuell
nicht
europa muss immer seine strategischen
Interessen schützen die Europäische
Kommission arbeitete an strengerin
investitionsprüfungen und einer
gemeinsamen Herangehensweise 2018 hatte
weniger als die Hälfte der
Mitgliedstaaten Regeln für die Prüfung
ausländischer Direktinvestitionen
aktuell wollen wir sicherstellen dass
die ganzen potenziellen Projekte Fähre
Wettbewerbsbedingungen vorfinden und
gemäß europäischer Standards finanziert
werden
in Europa wächst der Wunsch nach einer
genaueren Prüfung chinesischer
Investitionen wie beeinflusst das die
neue Seidenstraße
es gibt ein wachsendes Bewusstsein dass
wir zwar möglichst offen für
Investitionen aus dem Ausland sein
möchten wobei wir ohnehin der wohl
verschiedenste Markt der Welt sind
wir aber immer wissen müssen wer mit
welchem Ziel investiert
auch soll es insbesondere im Bezug auf
Politik und Menschenrechte weniger
vitomöglichkeiten einzelne
Mitgliedstaaten geben
es gab im Meer in Chinas durch die
Vorteile der neuen Seidenstraße und der
zugehörigen Infrastrukturentwicklung
strategisch Einfluss auf bestimmte
Länder zu nehmen
und diesen Einfluss dann zu ihrem
Vorteil zu nutzen
um die internationalen und politischen
Ziele Chinas zu unterstützen
Griechenland und Ungarn erhielten
beispielsweise bedeutende Unterstützung
im Rahmen der neuen Seidenstraße und
blockierten dann eine Stellungnahme der
EU die Chinas Bemühungen im
Südchinesischen Meer kritisierte
die EU ist sich Chinas Investitionen auf
Balkan und im Nahen Osten wohl bewusst
und strebt ihrerseits die Einrichtung
eines trans-europäischen Transportnetzes
nach europäischer Art an
Infrastrukturunternehmen wie die
china-communications construction
company treiben davon unbeirrt Verträge
in diesen Regionen voran der
ccc-vorsitzende leoji Tao gab uns ein
Interview und beteuerte er sehe trotz
strengerer Überwachung chinesischer
Investitionen großes Potenzial in Europa
wir haben strikte Standards für
Investitionen
sie müssen umweltfreundlich sein und der
Entwicklung des Landes und seines Volkes
nachhaltig helfen
wenn Regierungen wechseln werden unsere
Projekte oft angehalten und erneut
geprüft solange aber alle davon
profitieren machen wir gemeinsam weiter
manche Medien sehen das zwar anders aber
ich denke sie verstehen uns einfach
nicht
die EU hat die neue Seidenstraße nach
wie vor nicht abgesegnet und verweist
auf mangelnde Transparenz bezüglich der
Ausschreibungen und Umweltbedenken
sind diese Einwände berechtigt
wir müssen wechselseitiges Verständnis
schaffen und in diesem Fall mit
europäischen Firmen zusammenarbeiten
wenn unser Unternehmen stärker wird
verbessert sich die Transparenz also
arbeiten wir mit Europa an vielen
Projekten
ich bin neugierig wie gehen sie mit
Vorwürfen der Korruption gegenüber Ihrem
Unternehmen und einigen Projekten im
Rahmen der neuen Seidenstraße um in
World
wir gestatten unseren Funktionären
keinerlei korrupt des Verhalten so etwas
gibt es bei uns nicht das wäre nicht gut
für die nachhaltige Entwicklung der
Firma als gelistetes Unternehmen werden
wir zudem beaufsichtigt Korruption wäre
das Ende der Firma hier bleiben wir hart
Kritiker der neuen Seidenstraße
bemängeln die mangelnde Transparenz der
Projekte
die Anwerbung von chinesischen anstatt
lokalen Arbeitern und die Tatsache dass
Länder durch die Projekte am Ende China
gegenüber hoch verschuldet sind
dass diese Kritik zumindest teilweise
berechtigt ist ist doch nicht von der
Hand zu weisen oder
insgesamt wird die Transparenz sich
verbessern wenn die neue Seidenstraße
voranschreitet
bezüglich der Verschuldung manche Länder
müssen einfach mehr leihen wenn die
Wirtschaft des Landes stark genug wächst
sollte das aber keine Angst bereiten man
muss betrachten ob die so finanzierten
Projekte die Wirtschaft des Landes
fördern
Industrienationen müssen Ländern mit
entwicklungsdefiziten finanziell zur
Seite stehen
das Verhältnis ausländische Arbeiter ist
übrigens bei uns aktuell eins zu zehn
kommt auf einen chinesischen Arbeiter
kommen 10 ausländische die Lohnkosten
chinesische Arbeiter sind weit höher als
die lokaler Kräfte in
Entwicklungsländern sind die Lohnkosten
einfach geringer weshalb wir nach
Möglichkeit mehr lokale Arbeitskräfte
nutzen und dabei weniger chinesische
Arbeiter beschäftigen
es gibt natürlich Probleme und wir sind
nicht perfekt aber was man hört ist auch
falsch es fehlt das Verständnis
sowohl Europa als auch China sehen große
Wachstumschancen in der neuen
Seidenstraße
dennoch werden aufgrund mangelnder
Transparenz oft Bedenken laut da viele
der Beteiligten chinesischen Firmen in
staatlicher Hand sind
china muss sich bewusst werden dass
andere Länder oft eine Sichtweise der
neuen Seidenstraße haben die sich nicht
mit ihrer eigenen deckt
das wäre sehr wichtig es ist das
Aushängeschild von Präsident shijimpin
und wurde in die chinesische Verfassung
aufgenommen
die internationale Gemeinschaft sollte
herausfinden wo eine Partnerschaft mit
China bei der neuen Seidenstraße
sinnvoll wäre und wo die uns so
wichtigen internationalen Standards
erfüllt werden
wenn das nicht gegeben ist sollten wir
unsererseits seriöse
Alternativvorschläge machen die
internationalen Standards entsprechen
transparent und nachhaltig sind und
unsere Arbeits- und Umweltstandards
erfüllen
[Musik]
die Staats- und Regierungschefs Europas
sehen das Potenzial der neuen
Seitenstraße Chinas
um die vollständige Unterstützung der EU
zu sichern muss China jedoch den Worten
Taten folgen lassen und Transparenz
Nachhaltigkeit und Inklusion verbessern
einige europäische Firmen haben Gewinne
ins Auge gefasst die sind jedoch wohl
noch Jahre entfernt ich bin Tom McKenzie
danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]